good morning belief nation today we're
going to talk about why and how to find
your purpose in life right
the rant scared me cuz when the rats
score he don't say nothing
he ain't nobody excited he ain't trying
to get LeBron pissed off or pumped up he
just score my mana Shh
only thing he does at the end of the
game he kissed his mama he hugged his
brothers alright I'm out game over but
the one thing he does I don't know if
you watched it the first thing he does
when he gets on the court as he does
what y'all better start watching these
games bro
cuz you're gonna need to do what these
champions doing if you're gonna be a
champion the first thing he does just
what with them numbers he touched him
numbers on the front he touched him
numbers on the back and he's doing that
for who which coach his coach that was
killed his coach died at what age and he
wears what number he got a why he got a
while he just playing for no
championship he not you got to hear what
I'm telling you if y'all gonna be great
on that field you got to have a why you
got to have a reason for why you do what
you do when when he comes out he ain't
tripping on LeBron here he don't care
nothing about no Dewayne wait why he
keep thinking about it is I'm gonna get
one for my coach that's why he ain't on
smiling because why he's not smiling
because what he's trying to accomplish
he has not worked
he ain't got it yet he geeked about
winning no game he not addicted by
beating San Antonio he's not tripping
because they have one game that boy you
ain't gonna see that boys smile until
you get the championship and when he get
it he gonna hold up the problem would
some of y'all the reason why you don't
give a hundred and twenty percent every
doggone time you get on the field cuz
you ain't got a why for what you do you
ain't got a why I walk in the room I can
see some of y'all I spoke to all y'all
when y'all came in for the most part why
cuz I'm looking in your eyes and I see
some of y'all
you ain't serious and you think you want
to go out there with the Ray Lewis's of
the world Negro please when ray come out
you see the patch every game you see the
energy he come out every game like y'all
follow me follow my lead baby and we're
gonna win this thing what's your why hey
if I don't get y'all nothing else you
better start that what's your why you
know why I do what I do when I do it so
passionate cuz my grandfather was a high
school dropout my father was a high
school dropout I was a high school
dropout and we bout to break the cycle I
do what I do so my son won't have to go
through what I went through when I was
at the football game mile doing with me
I saw other kids with a fire I said
that'll never happen to me I do what I
do because my daughter says she's going
to Hartford ain't even about y'all I'm
about to come here and blaze y'all why
cuz I'm trying to get you all the NFL I
ain't bout to miss this opportunity this
is the first NFL team I've ever done in
my life and I'm about to lick it I'm
about to give everything I got and I
will know if I won't get another gig
it won't having to do with the fact that
I didn't put everything on the field
what's your why
passion often is linked with purpose
what I love to do is often what I should
do we have been created within us the
capacity to have things that we enjoy
greatly and a lot of times there is a
definite relationship between what I am
in love with and what I should be doing
we are created and wired in such a way
that that passion and purpose many times
comes together and passion is the great
energizer once you have passion you have
energy once you find your passion you
find your purpose
there is something energetic about it
you have never known a person who is
passionate that lacked energy we talked
about high energy people we talked about
low energy people there's no such thing
as like low energy people or high energy
people that if you have high energy you
have passion if you have low energy you
don't have any passion you know some
people there they're already dead they
haven't made it official yet
if you just look at it I just want to
walk around and do the committal let him
watch and observe the whole process but
passion gives us a great amount of
energy and when we have that pageant
there's something about how we love what
we're doing and we enjoy what we're
doing and passion energizes us Michael
Gerber the guy that wrote the e-myth you
know talks about why so many businesses
young businesses fail and one of these
things he says is most people are not
really entrepreneurs but they think
that's what they should be they think
that's the sexy thing that's the most
attractive thing that's the best answer
and what I say to you is you've got to
separate the vehicle from the outcome
what is it that's gonna truly fulfill
you what is it that's gonna give you
that extraordinary life what's gonna
make things magnificent on your terms
not somebody else's terms not your
father your mother your background what
is that really separate the vehicle
there's many ways to get to that vehicle
but I'm saying sometimes you got to
re-evaluate what's gonna really make you
fulfill what is your gift are you an
artist are you the talent can produce
something no one else produces as a
skill or a product or a service or some
impact are you incredibly good at
management you really know how to manage
or lead people are you an extraordinary
entrepreneur that has can take that
gigantic gut load of risk and can create
the vision and attract the talent that
you need and the managers and leaders
you may have all three abilities but
which one really fulfills you the most
is going to be the critical question
because we tend to want to do them all
especially the room like this because
you're all overachievers right me too
and you say well I can do all these yes
you can but what will it do to your
quality of life see again the secrets
gonna be this what is an extraordinary
life on your terms today getting clear
about that at this stage of life where
you are where you want to go people ask
Brendan how do I find my life's purpose
and I'm like you know gosh I can't find
a good haircut it is not an easy
question but I get it on stages around
the world when I'm speaking we get so
many submissions here to the show -
Brendan talk about life's purpose I mean
how do you
how do you find it and first and
foremost I'm not sure that you ever find
it I'm not sure that you wander outside
of your house one day and and the piano
of purpose falls on top of your head and
something like oh that's why I'm here I
think that purposes is more self defined
than just discovered suddenly one day
where the sudden answer emerges upon us
you know I think that we have to decide
what it is for ourselves but I think
that we have been given some clues you
know I don't pretend to know the answer
to what your life's purpose is or
anybody's life's purpose outside of even
my own and honestly my own is shifted
and and shaped its way throughout my
life to emerge into what it is today and
I'll share what I think mine might be
with you but I got mine just I think
everyone everyone else gets tears is
it's through that process of just asking
what are we about what do we want to
serve and give to the world what is it
that we want to stand for what do we
find meaningful in our own lives we can
ask a series of questions that might get
us closer but we shouldn't miss the
hints that are right in front of us
every single day I don't think that you
have to be you know operating just from
a place of religion or spirituality to
find that answer and often people go to
those two realms to find the answer I
think that's vital and it is important
and I found most of my inspiration from
this categories of life but I think just
as a realist looking around the world
you can observe that something is unique
about the human species about who we are
and and about maybe what that might give
us some indication into what life's
purpose might be for many of us and you
know that first thing if you look around
the world and you start paying attention
you start to notice that you know we're
all alive you know you're alive
I'm live if you're watching this you're
alive right and so maybe there's a
little hint there of a middle a hidden
sort of joke that if we are alive maybe
part of life's purpose is to be fully
alive how simple is that what if that
was your day you just say you know what
today I'm gonna be fully alive I'm gonna
feel an incredible sense of vibrancy and
joy and
and real zest and presents to my life
today because you know what what a gift
it is that I'm still here that I'm alive
you know and to really fully sense an
aliveness and to cultivate an aliveness
in our body and in our mind and in our
spirit so that we exude life to other
people you know you want to learn how to
be sexy or attractive to other people be
alive
right isn't that the people that were
most attracted to those those who are
just joyous and they have something
about their spirit there there's a
there's a spark there what we call a
charge you know there there's some kind
of internal charge about them that just
they stand out but you know what they
also feel differently by cultivating a
sense of aliveness and presence in our
life life feels different and if
everyone you talk about people whose
life purpose I mean everyone wants in
some way to feel you know alive alert
aware conscious because that's what we
have we've been given and so I just ask
what are you doing to make yourself feel
alive you know are you doing activities
that make draw out your passion are you
exude and and giving passion to the
world are you truly sensing the the
spirit and the joy and the energy of
this universe that makes you animated as
a human being and maybe those aren't
your things but they are for me I just
think what an incredible hint we're
alive
so be alive know what is the difference
between depression and joy right and I
think it's purpose right it's like when
you wake up in the morning and your life
means something to somebody other than
you that you have a purpose if you don't
go do the things that you're going to do
people's lives will suffer and I think
that that kind of purpose that like to
live in service not to you but to live
in service to humanity to live in
service to your family to live in
service to your church to your city to
your country to the world living in
service is that I feel like that is the
purest form of
ask yourself what's your purpose what
kind of contribution do you want to make
what creates joy and ecstasy in you what
are the two or three skills that you
have that when you're expressing your
unique talents or skills time means
nothing to you it's not work it's joy
ask yourself who are your heroes and
heroines in history mythology and
religion because these are archetypes
that are seeking to find expression
through you and incarnate through you
ask yourself how can this passion of
mind
contribute to relationship give meaning
and purpose to existence and you don't
need to know the answers if you live the
questions then life has an interesting
way of moving you into the answer thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Ali al Marzuki asked me to
so this is a topic that you want me to
cover in the next edition of believe
life leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which other points resonated with
you the most leave it in the comments
and I'm gonna join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you soon
I didn't want to just be a bodybuilding
champion I wanted to be the best body
build of all times dig deep down and ask
yourselves who do you want to be not
what but who I'm talking about figuring
out for yourselves what makes you happy
you have to think outside the box that's
what I believe after all what is the
point of being a nice girl if all you
want to do is be like that everyone and
avoid trouble you have so many rules in
life about everything I said break the
rules not the law but break the rules
I remember that nothing was finished
with my bodybuilding career I wanted to
get into acting there will be a spa
Phillips everyone has the same line that
it can't be done just looked at your
body here this huge monstrous body and
the overly developed that doesn't fit
into the movies but you know I didn't
listen to orders this but their rules I
was convinced they could do it then I
got the big break encountered the pub
area trust yourself no matter how what
anyone else thinks
and they're the directors say the people
wouldn't have smarts Nega we would have
to build one then when a determinator
I'll be back one of the most famous
lines in the movie history all because
of my crazy accent
just so's do you never listen that they
can't do something
don't be afraid to fail anything I've
ever attempted I was always willing to
fail
be afraid of making decisions you can't
get paralyzed that he'll failure or you
will never push yourself you can push it
because you believe in yourself and in
your vision
did you know that it's the right thing
to do it's a new concept no be afraid to
fail I mean how many times have you
heard that you can't do this you can't
do that it has never been done before so
pay no attention to the people say it
can't be done
I would've listened to the naysayers I
would still be the Austrian outs
yodeling
I would never come to America I always
listen to myself said yes you can
NMM on the veil because he didn't work
hard enough work you cut off
I always believed leaving no stone
unturned
no pain no gain
when you're out here party what's around
someone out there the same time is
working hard someone is getting smarter
and selfish waiting just remember them
you can't climb the ladder of success
with your hands in the pocket seven
billion plus people on the planet you're
different than every single one of them
there's a unique aspect to your
personality your style your intentions
your actions your habits your beliefs
who you are and the way that you think
is unique from everybody else we can
measure it by science we can measure it
by observation we can measure just by
simply asking people basic questions to
discover everyone's got their own
opinion everyone's got their own
worldview and because of that then we
have to ask well am i living my life
uniquely you know am I expressing who I
genuinely am are my expressions genuine
and authentic and spontaneous to Who I
am as a person or am i living a facade
you know am I trying to be somebody else
to please somebody else do gain
acceptance or love over here or am I
truly being true to myself to my unique
self to the inner side of who I really
am and what I want to show to the world
because a lot of people really you know
struggle with this and the reason they
start setting out to look for their
purpose in their life is one day they
woke up and they realize they're not
living their life they're living their
parents like their professors life their
teachers life they're they're living the
life that society or their culture or
their norms told them to live in one day
they wake up say whoa why have I
conformed to the point where I don't
even know who I am anymore and they
start this journey sometimes to look for
life's purpose because they're trying to
find themselves they're not looking for
a big purpose they're looking for
themselves and sometimes when we can tap
back into that uniqueness of who we are
then the magic of life comes alive again
you know that requires us to not only
exude who we are to the world but to
genuinely express who we are what we
think what we desire of life what we
need how we truly feel and think about
the people in our lives the things that
we are doing with our lives the places
and directions we're going we have to do
that if we want to
that full uniqueness of ourselves and
often it is by suppressing ourselves
that we begin to suffer and we have to
again ask well then what is the point of
all this is it to live as a you know as
a carbon copy of everybody else or to
fully with full intention and aliveness
animate the best of who we are uniquely
I think that you being yourself is a
grand purpose my soul is not contained
within the limits of my body my body is
contained within the limitlessness of my
soul I've often said that I wished
people could realize all their dreams
and wealth and fame and so that they
could see that it's not where you're
going to find your sense of completion I
can tell you from experience the effect
you have on others is the most valuable
currency there is because everything you
gain in life will rot and fall apart and
all that would be left of you is what
was in your heart
we're not the avatars we create we're
not the pictures on the film stock we
are the light that shines through all
else is just smoke and mirrors
distracting but not truly compelling
our eyes are not viewers they are also
projectors that are running a second
story over the picture that we see in
front of us all the time
fear is writing that script now fear is
going to be a player in your life but
you get to decide how much you can spend
your whole life imagining ghosts
worrying about the pathway to the future
but all there will ever be is what's
happening here in the decisions we make
in this moment which are based in either
love or fear so many of us choose our
path out of fear disguised as
practicality what we really want seems
impossibly out of reach and ridiculous
to expect so we never dare to ask the
universe for it I'm saying that you can
ask the universe for it life doesn't
happen to you it happens for you as far
as I can tell it's just about letting
the universe know what you want and
working toward it while letting go of
how it comes to pass why not take a
chance on faith not religion but faith
not hope but faith I don't believe in
hope hope is the beggar hope walks
through the fire and faith leaps over it
you are ready and able to do beautiful
things in this world and after you walk
through those doors today you will only
ever have two choices love or fear
choose love and don't ever let fear turn
you against your playful heart